[Music]
brien Keating's review of the big
picture on the origins of life meaning
and the universe itself by Bryan Keating
in physics today December 2016 at the
accepted rate of one picture per
thousand words
Sean Carroll's magnum opus the big
picture on the origins of life meaning
in the universe itself would be worth
about a hundred pictures Carol a
theoretical physicist at Caltech could
have easily entitled his book poetry for
physicists touching as it does on the
deepest cords of existence from
astrophysics to zoology we can begin as
carol does with definitions consider the
word universe religious interpretations
have it originating from the words 1 and
verse or from word as in the word or
verse said to be spoken by God in the
beginning the Roman philosopher
Lucretius one of the founders of
naturalism and a peripheral character in
the book is said to have coined the word
whose Latin translation means one role
to evoke everything enrolled or combined
into one this the sperrit view on the
seemingly innocuous word universe
perfectly capture the richness of the
big picture although there aren't many
new ideas in the big picture it shines
as a juxtaposition and synthesis of what
we physicists do no Carroll's book
contains the definitive treatment of a
wide range of subjects including quantum
entanglement bayes's theorem the Turing
test abiotic evolution the physically
relevant aspects of philosophy the
multiverse and of course the standard
model of physics the standard model is
the main focus of the tone which carol
calls the core theory a term coined by
Frank will check readers also receive
fresh insights into old standards such
as the entropic principle although
credulity might be stretched in
describing a 480 page book as lively
Carroll's humor shines in dry passages
such as those describing full employment
for philosophers or abducting God he is
adroit at quoting the secular Soren
Kierkegaard as the religious evangelist
Rick Warren he can mix Immanuel Kant
scat
coracle imperative with bill & ted's own
imperative be excellent to each other
few authors so deftly mix the weighty
with the buoyant and that compels us to
read on from working the bowels of
particle accelerators to being a lab rat
inside of an MRI machine Carol
skillfully pulls off a synthesis of all
his intellectual peripatetic ISM Carol's
fundamental thesis is that we know
enough about the core theory to describe
all that can affect us we should not
fear the paranormal or the astrological
if they have any reality whatsoever they
must obey the laws of nature the core
theory new observations may require us
to expand or adapt the core theory of
course but as Carol puts it we know
enough to draw very powerful conclusions
about the limits of what we do know one
need only take a cursory look at the
many extant glowing reviews of the big
picture to be convinced it's worth
purchasing I feel duty-bound therefore
to focus on my few qualms with the book
some of the material in the big picture
including Carol's descriptions of
concepts like entropy and the error of
time seems to be more or less adapted
from his earlier books jettisoning some
of that material might have somewhat
reduced the books heft but retaining it
is forgivable Carol's descriptions are
worth reading twice the big picture also
takes the ambitious step of addressing
ethics alongside its physics
Carol is devoutly secular but not by - /
- his bias towards naturalism is evident
but he implores physicists philosophers
and theologians to engage in serious
respectful dialogue can one imagine a
humanist 10 commandments Carol takes a
crack at just that although that may
seem like a fool's errand Carol's
version delights and inspires we do not
agree with it we must at least grapple
with it while believers must confront
the question of theodicy the existence
of evil and a universe governed by a
good God humanists must confront the
existence of goodness in a world
governed by survival of the fittest how
does one explain performing acts of
self-sacrifice or giving alms to the
poor in a purely physical world so red
in tooth and claw to quote Alfred Lord
Tennyson Carol admits that there cannot
be an absolute morality without God but
that does not prevent him from trying to
establish ethics from scientific
principal's Carol sees humans is good
however he must grapple with the fact
that although individuals are good
humanity as a whole has a very mixed
record in the end
Carol's claim that human values can
emerge from patterns is unconvincing if
there is indeed a sociological arrow of
time towards goodness and caring as
asserted it is difficult to appraise the
initial conditions that impelled it to
be so religious texts aren't scientific
texts they're not intended to be read as
science and they haven't been cited for
scientific purposes since Giordano Bruno
time but can physicalism catalyzed by
the core theory actually provide
spiritual meaning at the end Carol
admits we cannot dispense with the
claims of religions in its own and it's
in their own domains so why bother
trying to extend physics into the
religious or ethical realm clearly
religion fills lacunae in people's lives
for the gaps that remain there is the
big picture a manual for the majestic
poetic existence of all that is paul
dirac famously quipped in science one
tries to tell people in such a way as to
be understood by everyone something that
no one ever knew before but in the case
of poetry it's the exact opposite
unification of physics escaped Dirac
Carroll's version of poetic naturalism
attempts to unify the physical with the
ethereal with its delightful blend of
evocative love pounds and four
dimensional integrals the big picture
offers a uniquely physical vision of
life's meaning this is poetry for Carol
it comes naturally
[Music]